Good morning, everybody. Or afternoon or evening. You always ignore the afternoon people. Yeah, I'm sorry. Good afternoon. You know, but do people listen to podcasts in the afternoon? I guess they do. By the way, hello to all the people who are on a jog right now.
大家早上好。或者下午好，晚上好。你们总是忽略下午的人。好吧，抱歉。下午好。你知道，但人们会在下午听播客吗？我想会的。顺便说一句，向所有现在正在慢跑的人问好。
Hello. How are you? Keep pace. Watch the cracks. Hello, everybody at the supermarket. Hello, everybody who's driving. Check your mirrors. Those on the subway.
你好。你好吗？保持节奏。注意裂缝。大家好，超市里的朋友们。大家好，正在开车的朋友们。检查一下后视镜。还有地铁上的朋友们。
Don't miss your stop. That's right. Hello, everybody on a walk. Hello everybody who's driving, check your mirrors. Those on the subway, don't miss your stop. Hello everybody on a walk, just a regular walk. Everybody who's at work, come on, Janet. And for everyone else, welcome to Smartless. Smart. Bless. Smart. Bless. Oh wait, I got a quick one. I got a quick dad joke. What kind of bees make milk? Hmm. Will?
别坐过站了。没错。大家好，正在散步的朋友们。大家好，正在开车的朋友们，检查一下后视镜。地铁上的朋友们，别坐过站了。大家好，正在散步的朋友们，就是普通的散步。所有在工作的朋友们，加油，珍妮特。对于其他人，欢迎来到Smartless。Smart。Bless。Smart。Bless。哦等等，我有个简短的。我有个简短的冷笑话。什么蜜蜂产奶？嗯。威尔？
I don't know. Oobies. Will? I don't know. Boobies. Boo? Boobies. Boobies, yeah, I guess. Okay, I'll go with it. Sure. I think it's funny.
我不知道。Oobies。威尔？我不知道。Boobies。Boo？Boobies。Boobies，好吧，我想是吧。好吧，我接受。当然。我觉得挺好笑的。
Fuck, you wanted to say no so bad. You wanted to say no. No! I wanted to say no, that's not funny. Fuck. You have violated the pun law. All right, another dad joke, please. Sure. Go ahead, Sean.
该死，你那么想说不。你那么想说不。不！我想说不，那一点都不好笑。该死。你违反了冷笑话法。好吧，再来一个冷笑话，拜托。当然。来吧，肖恩。
My friend keeps saying, cheer up, man. It could be worse. You could be stuck underground in a hole full of water. I know he means well. Oh, I know he means well, right? Yeah, well, I didn't hit it. No, no, I know, but you might need to for some of our listeners.
我朋友一直说，振作点，伙计。情况可能会更糟。你可能会被困在地下一个装满水的洞里。我知道他是好意。哦，我知道他是好意，对吧？是的，好吧，我没打中。不，不，我知道，但你可能需要为我们的一些听众打中。
What about this one? What about this? Did that italics the well in your book? No. No. No? Go ahead. You know, a good elevator joke works on so many levels.
这个怎么样？这个呢？你书里的那个well是斜体的吗？不。不。不？说吧。你知道，一个好的电梯笑话在很多层面上都适用。
Sure. Ah! He got me. He got me. Nice reading. Come on, that's good. Okay. It's pretty good. Guys, I've said it before and I'll say it again.
当然。啊！他抓到我了。他抓到我了。读得不错。来吧，那很好。好吧。挺好的。伙计们，我以前说过，我还要再说一遍。
We three fools are incredibly lucky at times on this show to be able to ask some questions and hear some answers from folks who wouldn't otherwise spend even a second with us. Today's one of those days. Oh, I like that. Our next guest is one of the most important people to have been born in our generation. He is responsible for some of the most transformative ideas technologies and events the world has ever known and probably ever will
我们三个傻瓜在这个节目中有时非常幸运，能够向那些本来不会花一秒钟在我们身上的人提问并听到答案。今天就是这样的日子。哦，我喜欢这个。我们的下一位嘉宾是我们这一代出生的人中最重要的人之一。他负责了一些世界上已知，也可能永远已知的最具变革性的想法、技术和事件。
These discoveries advancements and innovations have made parts of our lives in the world around us far different than anyone could have even ever imagined Just 40 years ago. His work has brought him enormous wealth, which is enabling him to once again 40 years ago. His work has brought him enormous wealth, which is enabling him to once again change and help our planet and our lives in ways that are exciting, confusing, and in some ways, life-saving. Please welcome Mr. Bill Gates. Oh my gosh! Wow!
这些发现、进步和创新使我们周围的世界和我们的生活部分，与仅仅40年前任何人所能想象的完全不同。他的工作为他带来了巨大的财富，这使他能够再次改变并以令人兴奋、困惑，在某些方面甚至能挽救生命的方式帮助我们的星球和我们的生活。请欢迎比尔·盖茨先生。天哪！哇！
Mr. Bill Gates! Yeah. Hello, Mr. Gates. Hey guys. Wow! How lucky are we that we've got you now? This is so cool. We've got questions.
比尔·盖茨先生！耶。你好，盖茨先生。嘿，伙计们。哇！我们现在能请到你真是太幸运了？这太酷了。我们有问题要问。
Yeah, we've got questions. First of all, it looks like you're sitting in a high chair. I am. Oh. Well, this is a guy who probably does. I was gonna say, the guy does a lot of podcasts. I was thinking, why are you, I know you've got a very,
是的，我们有问题。首先，看起来你坐在高脚椅上。我是。哦。好吧，这是一个可能确实会这样的人。我本来想说，这家伙做了很多播客。我在想，为什么你，我知道你有一个非常，
thank God you've got a book coming out. I can't not wait to read it. But is that the only reason you're talking to us dummies? I mean, why, you've got so much important stuff to do. Sparing an hour for us is generous, but maybe foolish. It's relaxing. I don't know. So far.
谢天谢地你有一本书要出版。我迫不及待想读它。但这是你和我们这些笨蛋说话的唯一原因吗？我是说，为什么，你有那么多重要的事情要做。抽出一个小时给我们是慷慨的，但也可能是愚蠢的。这很放松。我不知道。到目前为止。
So we're not making you nervous at all. That's good. So far. Jason, I also can't wait for you to not read his book, but Bill Gates, welcome to the podcast. And I say that not because he won't be interested just the barely know us how to read And I will say is so exciting having you here as somebody who has been responsible for Not just innovations but just you know the impact that what you have done over the years has been incredible and not just in technology, etc and Really being on the on the cutting edge of that for years,
所以我们一点也没让你紧张。那很好。到目前为止。杰森，我也迫不及待地想让你不读他的书，但比尔·盖茨，欢迎来到播客。我这么说并不是因为他不会感兴趣，只是因为他几乎不认识我们，不知道怎么读。而且我要说的是，能有你在这里真是太令人兴奋了，作为一个人，你多年来所做的事情不仅是创新，而且你知道，这种影响是不可思议的，不仅仅是在技术等方面，而且确实多年来一直处于最前沿，
but all the philanthropic work you've done. I want to, I didn't know you were going to be here today, but I've been a big fan of your work in the philanthropic area. You've been a leader in that. You've really set a tone. So I applaud you and I thank you. And I wish more people would take your cue.
还有你所做的所有慈善工作。我想，我不知道你今天会来，但我一直是你慈善领域工作的忠实粉丝。你一直是那方面的领导者。你确实定下了一个基调。所以我为你鼓掌，我感谢你。我希望更多的人能效仿你。
Well, you're setting a great example. I think they will. I hope they will. Yeah, we really do. Pat, are they? I know you did something. What is it called? The giving pledge.
好吧，你树立了一个很好的榜样。我想他们会效仿的。我希望他们会。是的，我们真的希望。帕特，他们会吗？我知道你做了一些事情。它叫什么来着？捐赠誓言。
The giving pledge, yes, with Warren Buffett, right? Are guys, are men and women following along with that? Yeah, we have about 250 people who've made the commitment to give away the majority of their wealth. And we get together and learn from each other because philanthropy is actually a little confusing. You don't have like a rating system or profit
捐赠誓言，是的，和沃伦·巴菲特一起，对吧？伙计们，男男女女都在跟随吗？是的，我们大约有250人做出了捐出大部分财富的承诺。我们聚在一起互相学习，因为慈善事业实际上有点令人困惑。你没有像评级系统或利润那样的东西，
and it brings you into a new area. And so we can inspire each other, and hopefully anybody who's got lots of money feels like pitching in. Yeah, and because wasn't it, I think Warren Buffett said, because if you can't figure out how to live off of $500 million, there's a problem.
它把你带入了一个新的领域。所以我们可以互相激励，希望任何有很多钱的人都觉得可以参与进来。是的，因为不是吗，我想沃伦·巴菲特说过，因为如果你弄不清楚如何靠5亿美元生活，那就有问题了。
Isn't that what he's, isn't that part of that pact? That's right. I think I read that somewhere. I know, which is funny, because I was thinking about writing him a letter and asking him if he'd give me $500 million to see if I could do that. Yeah, just a little experiment. Do you know what I mean, read that somewhere. Which is funny, because I was thinking about writing him a letter and asking him if he'd give me 500 million to see if I could do that. Yeah, just a little experiment.
那不是他说的吗，那不是那个协议的一部分吗？没错。我想我在某处读到过。我知道，这很有趣，因为我当时在想给他写封信，问他是否愿意给我5亿美元，看看我能不能做到。是的，只是一个小实验。你知道我的意思，在某处读到过。这很有趣，因为我当时在想给他写封信，问他是否愿意给我5亿美元，看看我能不能做到。是的，只是一个小实验。
Do you know what I mean, as an experiment. So Mr. Gates, I'd like to ask you, if it's possible, Jason, sorry, I don't mean to hijack this. But- Be my guest. I've got some questions here if you run out. I'm sure, at risk of you having said this a million times before, would you talk a little bit about the genesis of Microsoft?
你知道我的意思，作为一个实验。所以盖茨先生，我想问你，如果可能的话，杰森，抱歉，我不是想劫持这个。但是——请便。如果你问完了，我这里还有些问题。我敢肯定，冒着你已经说过一百万遍的风险，你能谈谈微软的起源吗？
Because I don't know if I've ever really heard a clear story of how it came to be, how you had the idea for it, and how it came into fruition. Yeah, I was super lucky. You know, my parents found me a little confusing in terms of I was very good at some things and not good at other things. So they sent me to a private school and that school got a computer. So when I was 13, I had my first exposure and I got
因为我不知道我是否真的听过一个清晰的故事，关于它是如何产生的，你是如何有这个想法的，以及它是如何实现的。是的，我超级幸运。你知道，我的父母觉得我有点令人困惑，因为我在某些事情上非常擅长，而在其他事情上却不擅长。所以他们把我送到了一所私立学校，那所学校有一台电脑。所以当我13岁时，我第一次接触到了它，我变得
kind of obsessed with figuring it out, what it could do. And so even during high school, together with a friend, Paul Allen, I got thousands of hours of time learning how to write software. So forgive me for interrupting, what year was that that you got first exposed to the computer? And where?
有点痴迷于弄清楚它，它能做什么。所以即使在高中期间，我和一个朋友保罗·艾伦一起，我花了数千小时学习如何编写软件。所以原谅我打断一下，你第一次接触电脑是哪一年？在哪里？
That's 1968, I'm up in Seattle, Washington, at an excellent private school. And then Paul's 1968, I'm up in Seattle, Washington, at an excellent private school. And then Paul's reading and he sees that a computer's going to be done on a chip, the microprocessor made by people like Intel, and that those chips are gonna get twice as good every year or two. And so I say to Paul that that's exponential improvement,
那是1968年，我在华盛顿州西雅图的一所优秀的私立学校。然后保罗的1968年，我在华盛顿州西雅图的一所优秀的私立学校。然后保罗在阅读时看到电脑将在芯片上完成，即由英特尔等公司制造的微处理器，而且这些芯片每隔一两年就会好两倍。所以我对保罗说那是指数级的改进，
that then computers will be almost free and they'll need a lot of software, we should do that software. And he follows, when I go back to Harvard, because my parents wanted me to go to college, he follows me there to kind of bug me and say, well, this revolution is gonna happen, let's get going. And finally, when the first personal computer comes out
那么电脑将几乎免费，它们将需要大量的软件，我们应该做那个软件。当我要回哈佛时，因为我父母想让我上大学，他跟着我去了那里，有点烦我，说，好吧，这场革命将会发生，让我们开始吧。最后，当第一台个人电脑出来时，
in late 1974, I drop out and Paul and I found the company. And you told Steve Ballmer to stay behind, finish his education, because you're gonna need him later. Yeah, in fact, he shows up about four years into the company and he's the other person who plays an unbelievable role. I did manage to catch him in the middle of business school, so I got him to drop out of business school.
在1974年底，我退学了，保罗和我创立了公司。你告诉史蒂夫·鲍尔默留下来，完成他的学业，因为你以后会需要他。是的，事实上，他在公司成立四年后出现了，他是另一个扮演了不可思议角色的人。我确实设法在商学院中期抓住了他，所以我让他从商学院退学了。
There you go. So you see these computers in the sort of the late 60s that you're first exposed to are by comparison, of course to today, but maybe even to the computers in the mid 70s, rudimentary at best probably. Yeah, also very expensive. And so, you know, we only big companies
就是这样。所以你看到这些60年代末你第一次接触到的电脑，相比之下，当然是和今天相比，但也许甚至和70年代中期的电脑相比，充其量是原始的。是的，而且非常昂贵。所以，你知道，我们只有大公司
and the government have them. And so we would have to sneak in at night to get access. And, you know, we kept saying to people, these things are gonna be cheap, but they didn't, you know, they didn't agree, and so we got to be the very first people. And then you have people like Steve Jobs at Apple, where they're doing the hardware, the Apple II,
和政府才有它们。所以我们不得不晚上溜进去以获得访问权限。而且，你知道，我们一直对人们说，这些东西会变得便宜，但他们没有，你知道，他们不同意，所以我们成了第一批人。然后你有像苹果公司的史蒂夫·乔布斯这样的人，他们在做硬件，Apple II，
and we're doing the software. So the Apple computer came with our software. Oh, it did? Yeah, and was it, correct me if I'm wrong here, but I for some reason always thought that one of the major things that for small brains like me that really was like, oh, because I remember computers, there was the coding thing,
而我们在做软件。所以苹果电脑自带了我们的软件。哦，是吗？是的，而且是，如果我错了请纠正我，但我出于某种原因一直认为，对于像我这样的小脑瓜来说，真正让我觉得“哦”的主要事情之一，因为我记得电脑，有编码的东西，
and then all of a sudden one day there was, I think it was Windows, which was just point and click stuff, and it was like, oh, this is a whole different thing. Was that not you, Mr. Gates? Yes, absolutely. So the idea of the graphics interface, where you use images, not just characters,
然后突然有一天有了，我想是Windows，那只是点击式的东西，就像，哦，这是一个完全不同的东西。那不是你吗，盖茨先生？是的，绝对是。所以图形界面的想法，你使用图像，而不仅仅是字符，
that's pioneered at Xerox, which made a lot of money on copying machines, and they didn't manage to make a good product. So it's actually Apple with the Macintosh and Microsoft with Windows that takes this idea of graphics interface and takes it to the masses. And now everybody knows that's the way you use computers. You just point and click.
那是施乐公司开创的，他们在复印机上赚了很多钱，但他们没能做出一个好的产品。所以实际上是带有Macintosh的苹果和带有Windows的微软，将这种图形界面的想法带给了大众。现在每个人都知道这就是你使用电脑的方式。你只需点击。
But what we don't know is that underneath, what you're pointing on underneath that is a bunch of code that you're activating when just point and click. But what we don't know is that underneath, what you're pointing on underneath that is a bunch of code that you're activating when you hit a click. Yeah. It's actually pretty complicated underneath, which is why we had to hire lots of smart engineers and write a lot of code.
但我们不知道的是，在底层，你点击的东西下面是一堆代码，当你点击时你正在激活它。但我们不知道的是，在底层，你点击的东西下面是一堆代码，当你点击时你正在激活它。是的。底层实际上相当复杂，这就是为什么我们不得不雇佣很多聪明的工程师并编写很多代码。
But I will say, well, I have kind of two questions, which is A, so you learn on these rudimentary huge computers that only the government and educational institutions have, et cetera. So then, so you and Paul Allen realized that, okay, this is the future. Are there people who can teach you how to do the stuff you did,
但我会说，好吧，我有两个问题，即A，所以你在这些只有政府和教育机构才有的原始大型电脑上学习。那么，所以你和保罗·艾伦意识到，好吧，这就是未来。有人能教你如何做你所做的事情吗，
or did you have to figure a lot of that stuff out yourselves as you were going? We pretty much had to figure it out. I mean, we did hire a few adults, you know, who knew things like finance and accounting, but because we were at the forefront of a revolution, you know, this idea of, okay, how do you manage these people? How do you price this stuff?
还是你必须在进行过程中自己弄清楚很多事情？我们几乎必须自己弄清楚。我是说，我们确实雇佣了一些成年人，你知道，他们懂金融和会计之类的东西，但因为我们处于革命的最前沿，你知道，这种想法，好吧，你如何管理这些人？你如何给这些东西定价？
You know, and we decided we'd sell all over the world, so I have to build a team in Japan and Europe and deal with all the languages. I have to say it was super fun. And because we were right, these computers got so popular, we made enough money, we just kept hiring more and more people and eventually built Windows and Office, you know, which had Excel spreadsheet
你知道，我们决定在全世界销售，所以我必须在日本和欧洲建立团队，并处理所有的语言。我必须说这超级有趣。而且因为我们是对的，这些电脑变得如此受欢迎，我们赚了足够的钱，我们只是不断雇佣越来越多的人，最终建立了Windows和Office，你知道，它有Excel电子表格
and Microsoft Word and those became. You remember all that, yeah, yeah. So by the late 90s, we are doing well and it's kind of a standard way that people use personal computers. Yeah, I was. But, sorry, Sean, if I just, just on that last little bit of the code stuff,
和Microsoft Word，那些成为了。你记得所有这些，是的，是的。所以到90年代末，我们做得很好，这是人们使用个人电脑的一种标准方式。是的，我是。但是，抱歉，肖恩，如果我只是，只是关于代码的那最后一点，
and you touched on that, so that Apple products came with your software built in, and then you guys split, and it became kind of like the, and forgive me for the comparison, you became like the VHS Betamax. It was either or, it was like, you either did this or you did that.
你提到了这一点，所以苹果产品内置了你的软件，然后你们分道扬镳了，它变得有点像，原谅我的比较，你们变得像VHS和Betamax。要么是这个，要么是那个，就像，你要么做这个，要么做那个。
Was there ever a discussion between you and Steve Jobs about, hey, let's continue in this partnership using your, et cetera, et cetera? Did you guys, or was there a moment that you split? Because we're always pure software, the only competition is that they, Apple does its own operating system, which competes with Windows,
你和史蒂夫·乔布斯之间有没有讨论过，嘿，让我们继续这种合作关系，使用你的，等等等等？你们有没有，或者有没有一个时刻你们分开了？因为我们一直是纯软件，唯一的竞争是他们，苹果做自己的操作系统，这与Windows竞争，
but we write software on the Macintosh. In fact, we had as many people as Steve Jobs did when he's doing the Macintosh, because we do our word processor, we do our spreadsheet, and it was amazing because, you know, Steve did the Mac. That was wonderful. Then he leaves Apple.
但我们在Macintosh上编写软件。事实上，当史蒂夫做Macintosh时，我们拥有的人数和他一样多，因为我们做我们的文字处理器，我们做我们的电子表格，这太神奇了，因为，你知道，史蒂夫做了Mac。那太棒了。然后他离开了苹果。
Apple's being very mismanaged. When he comes back, I reach a deal with him where we actually invest in Apple and commit to do our software. And then he runs that company so well that going from the verge of failure, it actually becomes the most valuable company in the world, even slightly more valuable than Microsoft.
苹果管理得很糟糕。当他回来时，我和他达成了一项协议，我们实际上投资了苹果并承诺做我们的软件。然后他把那家公司经营得非常好，从濒临失败，它实际上成为了世界上最有价值的公司，甚至比微软稍微更有价值一点。
That's amazing. So we ended up working together. And then in the last few years when he was sick, we got to reflect on our lives and talk to each other quite a bit. We were kind of competitors. I mean, he would criticize Windows pretty brutally, but that's okay. But his skillset, which was kind of design
那太神奇了。所以我们最终一起工作了。然后在最后几年他生病时，我们有机会反思我们的生活并进行了相当多的交谈。我们算是竞争对手。我是说，他会非常残酷地批评Windows，但这没关系。但他的技能，也就是设计
and user interface, he was not an engineer. And so my skill is very much as an engineer. So we appreciated each other. You know, of course. Yeah. Was there a lot of competition though? Like there had to be, when you're sitting in your garage or wherever you were with Paul thinking, you know,
和用户界面，他不是工程师。所以我的技能非常像工程师。所以我们互相欣赏。你知道，当然。是的。不过竞争激烈吗？就像一定有，当你坐在车库里或者无论你和保罗在哪里思考，你知道，
designing this and coming up with this and all that stuff, back then you didn't have the, people didn't know what you were doing, right? Everybody knows what everybody's doing now. And so you didn't, you had this kind of secrecy so you could protect yourself. But as it grew and became the thing that it became, how do you protect yourself
设计这个并想出这个以及所有这些东西时，那时你没有，人们不知道你在做什么，对吧？现在每个人都知道每个人在做什么。所以你没有，你有这种保密性，这样你就可以保护自己。但随着它的成长并成为它所成为的东西，你如何保护自己
and how did you protect yourself from competitors? And was Apple the only competitor? Because Microsoft wasn't about any one piece of software, not just Windows, not just Office, we were doing Xbox, which had games. We thought of ourselves as a software factory and we wanted to be faster than anyone else and have lower price software than anyone else.
以及你如何保护自己免受竞争对手的伤害？苹果是唯一的竞争对手吗？因为微软不仅仅是关于任何一个软件，不仅仅是Windows，不仅仅是Office，我们在做Xbox，它有游戏。我们把自己看作是一个软件工厂，我们想比任何人都快，并且拥有比任何人都低的价格的软件。
And so the other people doing software found it pretty intimidating that we moved at that speed. And that's why when Steve does the Macintosh, he comes to us and says, hey, are you willing to bet on this? Can we work on this together? It got quite competitive. Eventually other great companies like Google come along,
所以其他做软件的人发现我们以那种速度移动非常令人生畏。这就是为什么当史蒂夫做Macintosh时，他来到我们这里说，嘿，你愿意赌这个吗？我们可以一起做这个吗？竞争变得相当激烈。最终其他伟大的公司像谷歌出现了，
and they're also very good at hiring smart people. And there's been room, you know, if you think of what are the most valuable companies in the world today, it's all these companies that ushered in this digital revolution. Right, yeah, I was gonna say, because now you have, instead of Google, Microsoft, and Apple, you have 200 AI companies now,
他们也非常擅长雇佣聪明人。而且有空间，你知道，如果你想想今天世界上最有价值的公司是什么，它们都是引领这场数字革命的公司。对，是的，我本来想说，因为现在你有，不是谷歌、微软和苹果，你现在有200家人工智能公司，
because people see the future much more quickly now than they did then. Sean, Sean, and tell Mr. Gates, you're an Ask Jeeves guy, right? Like that's been your whole- An Ask Jeeves. Mr. Gates, do you remember having conversations with Paul or Steve or any of your contemporaries at the time, do you remember
因为人们现在比那时更快地看到了未来。肖恩，肖恩，告诉盖茨先生，你是个Ask Jeeves的人，对吧？就像那是你的整个——一个Ask Jeeves。盖茨先生，你还记得和保罗或史蒂夫或你当时的任何同时代人进行过对话吗，你还记得
sitting there having conversations with them and allow yourself the imagination for what the future could bring and were there any things that were worrisome or exciting like you hear about the conversations that are happening now regarding AI, where we're kind of on the doorstep of another big move. Do you remember having those concerns back then? Were there any? Yes, so the digital revolution with PCs and internet, we thought of as very empowering.
坐在那里和他们交谈，并允许自己想象未来能带来什么，有没有什么令人担忧或令人兴奋的事情，就像你听到现在关于人工智能的对话一样，我们有点处于另一次大动作的门口。你还记得当时有那些担忧吗？有吗？是的，所以个人电脑和互联网的数字革命，我们认为是非常赋能的。
And so you could say we were kind of naive in thinking this was all good. In fact, when we worried, we were worried about what we called the digital divide, that having access was so valuable that we should make sure that schools in the inner city and poor countries had the internet and the PC. It's only when social networking comes along
所以你可以说我们在认为这一切都是好事方面有点天真。事实上，当我们担心时，我们担心的是我们所谓的数字鸿沟，即拥有访问权限非常有价值，我们应该确保内城的学校和贫穷国家拥有互联网和个人电脑。只有当社交网络出现时
that this kind of, oh, isn't it always for the good to give people new capabilities, we realized, wow, the social criticism, the waste of time that in some ways, we were playing to human weaknesses that you seek out outrage and that kind of can drive people apart. And now, that we've seen
这种，哦，给人们新能力难道不总是为了好事吗，我们意识到，哇，社会批评，在某些方面浪费时间，我们是在利用人类的弱点，你寻求愤怒，那种东西可以把人们分开。现在，我们已经看到
that those advances aren't always good. Now with AI, which is far more powerful than social network, we're going, wow, how do we shape this thing to get the good, which is definitely there, but avoid the bad stuff? And it's a little bit scary right now. Well, a little bit trying to put the genie back in the bottle, unfortunately, with the social networks
那些进步并不总是好的。现在有了人工智能，它比社交网络强大得多，我们正在想，哇，我们如何塑造这个东西以获得好处，这绝对是存在的，但避免坏的东西？现在有点可怕。好吧，有点试图把精灵放回瓶子里，不幸的是，对于社交网络
and also just with phones in general and their impacts. You know, as a father of three boys under the age of 16 and younger, I would ask you, and I know your kids are a little bit older, and I, look, I don't like answering the hypothetical questions myself, but I'm gonna ask you a hypothetical, which is, and feel free to not answer it.
以及对于手机及其影响。你知道，作为一个16岁以下三个男孩的父亲，我会问你，我知道你的孩子稍微大一点，而且我，看，我自己不喜欢回答假设性问题，但我会问你一个假设，即，请随意不回答。
If your kids were teenagers again, if they were adolescents, if they were 11, 12, 13, 14, would you let them have access to social media? Yeah, my youngest, I stopped her from having a cell phone until she was 14. And she was quite upset because the other kids had access. It works a lot better if groups of parents or even the school come in and saying,
如果你的孩子再次成为青少年，如果他们是青少年，如果他们是11、12、13、14岁，你会让他们使用社交媒体吗？是的，我的小女儿，我阻止她使用手机直到她14岁。她非常生气，因为其他孩子有访问权限。如果家长群体甚至学校进来并说，
hey, during the school day, this is pretty distracting. And Australia is now trying to pass a set of rules. There's a book by Jonathan Haidt called The Anxious Generation. Oh, we've talked about it a lot. I've read it. Okay, good, good. And his point that we're kind of overprotecting kids
嘿，在学校期间，这非常令人分心，效果会好得多。澳大利亚现在正试图通过一套规则。有一本乔纳森·海特写的书叫《焦虑的一代》。哦，我们谈论过很多次了。我读过。好的，好的。他的观点是，我们在现实世界中有点过度保护孩子
in the real world and underprotecting them in the digital world, I think he's got a super good point there and we've got to step up on it. I took his advice and I said to my boys, to my teenage boys, I said, I will give you a lot of freedoms in the real world that are commensurate with your reduction in your time in the digital world and I will give you much more leeway to do stuff
而在数字世界中保护不足，我认为他在这方面有一个超级好的观点，我们必须加强这一点。我采纳了他的建议，我对我的男孩们，对我的青少年男孩们说，我会在现实世界中给你很多自由，这与你在数字世界中时间的减少相称，我会给你更多的余地去做事情
and spend time in real time and give you a later curfew on the weekend, sort of 11.30 if you will, or whatever that is, if you guys, if I see a market reduction in your time online. But what I dream about, this is what I'm getting to, what I dream of is six months of no social media on this planet, and what would that do
并花时间在实时中，如果你愿意，周末给你更晚的宵禁，11点半，或者无论那是什么，如果你们，如果我看到你们在线时间有显著减少。但我梦想的是，这就是我要说的，我梦想的是这个星球上六个月没有社交媒体，那会做什么
in a sort of a social, in a reset? Imagine a world where we didn't have that. I personally think that we would be in a much better place. Yeah, when you see how polarized we are and that, you know, even I, if there's some article criticizing somebody I don't like, I'm like, oh, yeah, I wanna be outraged against the people I think have shortcomings.
在某种社会，在重置中？想象一个没有那个的世界。我个人认为我们会处于一个更好的地方。是的，当你看到我们是多么两极分化，而且，你知道，即使是我，如果有一篇批评我不喜欢的人的文章，我会想，哦，是的，我想对那些我认为有缺点的人感到愤怒。
And so, you know, you want an algorithm that brings us together, and maybe a moratorium would help us get there. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. My, you know, as a kid who grew up in the seventies, as a Gen Xer, you know, your rise
所以，你知道，你想要一个把我们聚集在一起的算法，也许暂停一下会帮助我们到达那里。是的。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。我的，你知道，作为一个在七十年代长大的孩子，作为一个X世代，你知道，你的崛起
and your significance in the world coincided with sort of my teenage years and understanding that kind of thing. And it felt like the first time that we had things like the, you know, the fortune lists or the Forbes or the richest people in the world. And your name was in and out of the top of that for many, many years.
以及你在世界上的重要性与我十几岁的时候以及理解那种事情相吻合。感觉就像我们第一次有了像，你知道，财富榜或福布斯或世界上最富有的人这样的东西。你的名字在很多很多年里都在那个榜单的顶部进进出出。
And I can't imagine just how absurd that must be on a certain level. Did you have those moments of like, not even pinch me, but of like, is this me? It feels almost abstract, how bizarre. Did you have that at all? Or just leave me alone? Well, it's definitely wild.
我无法想象在某种程度上那一定有多荒谬。你有过那种时刻，甚至不是掐我，而是像，这是我吗？感觉几乎是抽象的，多么离奇。你完全没有过吗？还是只是让我一个人呆着？好吧，这绝对是疯狂的。
At a young age, I was in my 30s when I become the richest person. At a young age, I was in my 30s when I become the richest person. And my parents, fortunately, their values helped anchor me. And they were always saying, okay, to whom much is given, much is expected.
在年轻时，我在30多岁时成为最富有的人。在年轻时，我在30多岁时成为最富有的人。我的父母，幸运的是，他们的价值观帮助锚定了我的心。他们总是说，好吧，被给予很多的人，被期望很多。
So I did start in my 40s to really study philanthropy, Rockefeller, Carnegie, what had they done, and try and figure out, could I be as careful about giving it back? And then in my 50s, I retired from Microsoft and moved over to do foundation work full-time. But yes, it's bizarre. Having close friends who really know you,
所以我确实在40多岁时开始真正研究慈善，洛克菲勒，卡内基，他们做了什么，并试图弄清楚，我能像那样小心地回馈吗？然后在50多岁时，我从微软退休，转而全职做基金会工作。但是的，这很离奇。有真正了解你的亲密朋友，
who can laugh about your success, I think, you know, does help keep you grounded. Yeah, I love that. That transition to philanthropy, I'm sure there are many parts of it that are even more complicated than your life beforehand. Many, many challenges. Can you speak about those?
他们可以嘲笑你的成功，我认为，你知道，确实有助于让你保持脚踏实地。是的，我喜欢那个。那种向慈善事业的转型，我相信其中有很多部分比你之前的生活更复杂。很多，很多挑战。你能谈谈那些吗？
I'm sure there's a lot of it that is much more enjoyable too, probably most of it. How is that feeling, that transition? Well, I loved being a individual contributor in my 20s and then managing Microsoft in my 30s, where you're just very hands-on and you can say, my product is selling well or this one is not. How do we fix that?
我相信其中有很多也更令人愉快，可能大部分都是。那种感觉如何，那种转型？好吧，我喜欢在20多岁时做个人贡献者，然后在30多岁时管理微软，在那里你非常亲力亲为，你可以说，我的产品卖得很好或者这个卖得不好。我们如何解决这个问题？
And so it's a real switch, you know, where you're not having that immediate market feedback to go and say, hey, why do children die? How many children die? Can we reduce that? And then I had to learn about poor countries and vaccines. But I have to say it's been as fulfilling. In the turn of the century,
所以这是一个真正的转变，你知道，你没有那种即时的市场反馈去说，嘿，为什么孩子会死？有多少孩子死亡？我们能减少那个吗？然后我不得不学习贫穷国家和疫苗。但我必须说它一直很充实。在本世纪之交，
we have 10 million children dying every year. And because we got out new vaccines and worked with partners, that's now down below five million a year. And if we keep doing our work well, including governments caring about poor countries, we can cut that in half again to two and a half million. Sorry, is there, have you found a way
我们每年有1000万儿童死亡。因为我们拿出了新的疫苗并与合作伙伴合作，现在每年下降到500万以下。如果我们继续做好我们的工作，包括政府关心贫穷国家，我们可以再次将其减半至250万。抱歉，有没有，你找到了一种方法
to make it an attractive idea for countries to come on and partner with you that goes beyond just the obvious ethical and moral pole of it? Is there a GDP component that you can dangle in front of some of these more capitalistic minded countries that get them to the table a little bit better? Yeah, that's a super good point is, you know, we, of course the moral argument of the golden rules, you know, helping people everywhere is our strongest argument,
让国家加入并与你合作成为一个有吸引力的想法，超越了明显的道德和伦理吸引力？有没有一个GDP成分，你可以悬在一些这些更资本主义思想的国家面前，让他们更好地来到谈判桌前？是的，这是一个超级好的观点，你知道，我们，当然金科玉律的道德论点，你知道，帮助各地的人是我们最强的论点，
but that alone isn't gonna get us there. You know, we had some of the generals in the US Army saying, hey, if you don't help these countries out, then we'll have to go to war and you'll have to increase our budget. So that the foreign aid budget, by creating stability, it avoids the awful war. And also, if you lift people up economically,
但这单独不会让我们到达那里。你知道，我们有一些美国陆军的将军说，嘿，如果你不帮助这些国家，那么我们将不得不去打仗，你将不得不增加我们的预算。所以外交援助预算，通过创造稳定，它避免了可怕的战争。而且，如果你在经济上提升人们，
like Asia today, buys a lot of American stuff, movies, drugs, jets, software, you name it. So our mutual success has been amazing. The two countries we defeat in World War II were generous enough to them that they become the second and third biggest economy and we engage in mutually beneficial trade. Japan shows us how to make quality products
像今天的亚洲，购买很多美国的东西，电影、药品、喷气式飞机、软件，应有尽有。所以我们的共同成功是惊人的。我们在二战中击败的两个国家，对他们足够慷慨，以至于他们成为第二和第三大经济体，我们进行互利贸易。日本向我们展示了如何制造优质产品
and now we want to extend that and get, Asia's doing well, India's getting rich and eventually they don't need aid if you help them out and so you only have mostly countries in Africa that still really deserve this kind of support. Are you finding that you're having the same kind of messaging, language success as you try to encourage them to come along with environmental adjustments as well,
现在我们想扩展这一点并获得，亚洲做得很好，印度正在变富，最终如果你们帮助他们，他们就不需要援助了，所以你只有大部分在非洲的国家仍然真正值得这种支持。你是否发现你在试图鼓励他们也进行环境调整时，
that it's mutually beneficial from a business standpoint, et cetera? Yeah, so environmentally, a lot of these poor countries are very beautiful and we all have to deal with climate change. Sadly, it's these African countries that didn't contribute to that problem at all because they're outdoor farmers near the equator.
有同样的信息、语言成功，即从商业角度来看它是互利的，等等？是的，所以在环境方面，很多这些贫穷国家非常美丽，我们都必须应对气候变化。可悲的是，正是这些非洲国家根本没有造成那个问题，因为他们是赤道附近的户外农民。
They're the ones that are suffering the most. The countries we need to really change their emissions are these middle income countries. So China, Brazil, now India. And they expect us to help them by inventing really inexpensive ways to go green. And so the biggest hope for the environmental stuff is innovation.
他们是受苦最深的人。我们需要真正改变排放的国家是这些中等收入国家。所以中国、巴西，现在是印度。他们期望我们通过发明真正廉价的绿色方式来帮助他们。所以环境方面最大的希望是创新。
If the green stuff is really expensive, even the rich countries are kind of saying, hey, don't make me buy an electric car if it costs more, don't make me buy an electric heat pump. And so, you know, it's gonna have to be all of us saying we're in this together, it's one planet, but also a lot of innovation, because nobody can agree if it's expensive,
如果绿色东西非常昂贵，即使是富裕国家也都在说，嘿，如果成本更高，别让我买电动车，别让我买电动热泵。所以，你知道，这将不得不是我们所有人说我们在一起，这是一个星球，但也需要很多创新，因为如果它很昂贵，没有人能同意，
who should pay for it. Right, a friend of mine who's sort of, a friend of ours, friend of the show, Willie, our buddy, he mentioned that there, with this big round of deregulation that supposedly is on its way, that there may be a good spin to it in that the amount of innovation that is needed to really make a big move in an environment,
谁应该为此买单。对，我的一个朋友，他是某种，我们的一个朋友，节目的朋友，威利，我们的伙伴，他提到，随着这一轮据称即将到来的大规模放松管制，它可能有一个好的转折，即真正要在环境中做出大动作所需的创新量，
a part of that, it's necessary for private to be spending money there as well as just federal money. And so by deregulating, you give those companies more money to spend in R&D for these environmental things. Is that just spin for the business sector? And I'll let you guess what business he's in. But he's a great guy.
其中一部分，私营部门在那里花钱以及仅仅是联邦资金是必要的。所以通过放松管制，你给那些公司更多的钱去为这些环境问题进行研发。那只是商业部门的转折吗？我会让你猜他在什么行业。但他是个很棒的人。
What do we think about that? Is that spin or is there some validity to that? No, there's definitely some validity. For example, if you want to build an electricity transmission line, you often have to go through almost a decade of approvals. And of course, that line, if anybody blocks it, then it doesn't work at all. And so we need to have more collective action as we try and change,
我们怎么看那个？那是转折还是其中有一些有效性？不，绝对有一些有效性。例如，如果你想建造一条输电线路，你通常必须经历近十年的审批。当然，那条线，如果有人阻挡它，那么它根本不起作用。所以我们需要在尝试改变时有更多的集体行动，
you know, move away from coal, electricity, to other things, which is sun and wind and nuclear and a variety of things. We don't want to get rid of all the regulations because part of the reason the US is so beautiful, we preserve lands, we've cleaned up our waters better than any other country. But it is absolutely fair to say that many of these
你知道，从煤炭、电力转向其他东西，即太阳能、风能、核能和各种各样的东西。我们不想摆脱所有的法规，因为美国如此美丽的其中一个原因是，我们保护土地，我们清理水域比任何其他国家都好。但绝对公平地说，许多这些
environmental reviews are delaying projects that we need in order to solve climate change. Gotcha, so government could get out of the way a little bit because we got to work fast, right, but not completely? Yes, so we're going to have to strike that balance. Well, it's so hard not to be cynical when you have things like,
环境审查正在推迟我们需要解决气候变化的项目。明白了，所以政府可以稍微让开一点，因为我们必须快速工作，对吧，但不是完全让开？是的，所以我们将不得不达成那种平衡。好吧，当你有像这样的事情时，很难不愤世嫉俗，
and you were just touching on the idea, Jason, it was part of the big thing, your question, which is this, that, yeah, of course there is, you know, the what you call the ethical or moral pull, but it always comes down to economics, right? It's always, sadly, it's the driver of everything. It's like when the government went to war on the cigarette companies,
你刚才提到了这个想法，杰森，这是大事情的一部分，你的问题，即这个，即，是的，当然有，你知道，你所说的道德或伦理吸引力，但它总是归结为经济学，对吧？它总是，可悲的是，它是所有事情的驱动力。就像政府对香烟公司发动战争时，
it wasn't because they wanted us to stop smoking, it's because they didn't want to pay for people who were sick, unfortunately. It's gotta be a win-win. Ultimately, otherwise they wouldn't, they wanted us to stop smoking, it's because they didn't want to pay for people who were sick. Unfortunately. It's got to be a win-win. Ultimately. Otherwise, they wouldn't, they couldn't care less. And I think that there is a societal issue in America. Mr. Gates, I haven't revealed this to you yet.
并不是因为他们想让我们停止吸烟，而是因为他们不想为生病的人买单，不幸的是。它必须是双赢的。最终，否则他们不会，他们想让我们停止吸烟，是因为他们不想为生病的人买单。不幸的是。它必须是双赢的。最终。否则，他们不会，他们根本不在乎。而且我认为美国存在一个社会问题。盖茨先生，我还没向你透露这一点。
I'm Canadian by birth. Oh, God. So, and I'm sorry to drop it on you like that. We had a reveal party. But, you know, I think that there is a societal, there are some societal issues, and I am American as well, and I've lived here for a number of years,
我是加拿大人。哦，天哪。所以，我很抱歉那样告诉你。我们有一个揭秘派对。但是，你知道，我认为存在一个社会，存在一些社会问题，我也是美国人，我在这里住了很多年，
and I love this country. I truly, truly do, and my children are all American. It's an incredible experience. But I do think that there are some issues, societally, in this country that come up, that have to do with that that unfortunately I know that look, I'm not naive, but unfortunately, a lot of things in this country are driven by people wanting to what's theirs.
我爱这个国家。我真的，真的爱，我的孩子们都是美国人。这是一次不可思议的经历。但我确实认为这个国家在社会上存在一些问题，这些问题出现，与那个有关，不幸的是，我知道看，我并不天真，但不幸的是，这个国家的很多事情是由人们想要属于他们的东西所驱动的。
And there isn't this idea that we're only as strong as our weakest link. It just and if any and if anything, it keeps getting reinforced in different ways in elections, etc. in the way that you look at, California should have buried power lines. There's no question about it, but nobody wants to pay for that kind of thing. And so there are all sorts of things like that, and people just won't do it.
而且没有这种我们只有最薄弱环节那么强大的想法。它只是，如果有什么，它在选举中以不同的方式不断得到加强，等等，在你看来，加利福尼亚应该掩埋电力线。毫无疑问，但没有人想为那种事情买单。所以有各种各样的事情，人们就是不会做。
And I don't know how we can change minds in this country, but it is strange. And people will vote against their self-interest in this country in ways that are staggering and and I I'm giving you all these big picture things because I imagine mr. Gates these are the kinds of things that you think about because you're dealing in macro am I right with that no absolutely the you know I when I think about the health system or climate,
我不知道我们怎么能改变这个国家的想法，但这很奇怪。人们会以令人震惊的方式投票反对自己的利益，而且我，我给你所有这些大局观的东西，因为我想象盖茨先生，这些是你思考的事情，因为你在处理宏观，我说的对吗？不，绝对，你知道，当我想到卫生系统或气候时，
we've gotta solve these problems. We saw that when we weren't ready for the pandemic, millions of people died who shouldn't have died. Go ahead, Sean. I was just saying, I love all the, talking about medicine, I love all the medical things you're doing. Do I call you Bill?
我们必须解决这些问题。我们看到当我们没有为大流行做好准备时，数百万本不该死的人死了。说吧，肖恩。我只是想说，我喜欢所有，谈论医学，我喜欢你正在做的所有医疗事情。我叫你比尔吗？
Do I call you Mr. Gates? Sure, Bill's fantastic. Okay, William. It's a great name, Bill. I do think you should keep it. It is a great name. I've been thinking about it. It is a great name.
我叫你盖茨先生吗？当然，比尔太棒了。好的，威廉。这是一个伟大的名字，比尔。我确实认为你应该保留它。这是一个伟大的名字。我一直在想它。这是一个伟大的名字。
Trey, we can call you Trey? Trey. That was my nickname. Yeah? My family still calls me that because my dad was Bill. Right. Wait, where'd you get Trey? The third.
特雷，我们可以叫你特雷吗？特雷。那是我的昵称。是吗？我的家人仍然那样叫我，因为我爸爸是比尔。对。等等，你从哪里得到特雷的？第三。
The third. Because he's the third. Trey is the third. Oh, hey Trey. You didn't know that? So hey Trey, I love all the medical things you're involved with. And so what's your favorite one you're working on and how has all being around all the innovation
第三。因为他是第三。特雷是第三。哦，嘿特雷。你不知道吗？所以嘿特雷，我喜欢你参与的所有医疗事情。那么你正在做的你最喜欢的是哪一个，以及所有围绕所有创新是如何
of this medical world that you're involved with changed the way you live your life, whether that's food, diet, or whatever it is that we don't know about. We're learning a lot. We've learned that sleep is very important. On nutrition, we're still kind of confused about other than eating too many calories, what counts.
你所参与的这个医学世界改变了你的生活方式，无论是饮食、节食还是其他我们所不知道的事情。我们正在学习很多东西。我们了解到睡眠非常重要。在营养方面，除了摄入过多的卡路里，我们对于什么才是关键仍然感到困惑。
The work of our foundation is very focused on the diseases that are still huge in poor countries. So HIV, malaria, you know, we literally still have polio out there, even though we got rid of it in the US and kids aren't dying and being paralyzed. But we're down to just a few countries. And so the only disease we've ever gotten rid of is smallpox, and now polio is very close to being the second
我们基金会的工作非常专注于那些在贫困国家仍然非常严重的疾病。比如艾滋病、疟疾，你知道，尽管我们在美国已经消灭了脊髓灰质炎，孩子们不再因此死亡或瘫痪，但实际上这种病在外面依然存在。我们现在只剩下几个国家还有这种病。我们唯一彻底消灭的疾病是天花，而现在脊髓灰质炎非常接近成为第二个
on that list, so I put a lot of effort into that. With HIV, you've got a million Americans living with it, 40 million worldwide. We'd like to make it so we can actually cure it rather than you having to take medicine the rest of your life. And so we're making good progress on that. Is there any truth to the fact that,
名单上的疾病，所以我在这方面投入了大量精力。关于艾滋病，美国有一百万人携带病毒，全球有四千万人。我们希望能够真正治愈它，而不是让你余生都必须服药。所以我们在这方面取得了很好的进展。关于这一点有什么真实性吗？
because I hear like they actually, you know, you hear these conspiracies that there actually is a cure for HIV or there is a cure for all these things, but they suppress it because there's too much money in pharmaceuticals. No, I wish that was true, because then I would take the cure and, you know. Right, exactly.
因为我听说，你知道，你会听到这些阴谋论，说其实有艾滋病的疗法，或者有所有这些疾病的疗法，但因为制药业利润太高，他们把疗法压制了。不，我希望那是真的，因为那样我就会采用那种疗法，你知道的。对，没错。
Do you know about this? Gosh, now it just occurred to me, now that you're here, I'm going to call you Bill as well, if that's okay. Good. Bill, I know, because I've been reading online, and a lot of people from their basement say that you're putting chips in our brain, which is amazing.
你知道这个吗？天哪，现在我突然想到，既然你在这儿，我也要叫你比尔，如果可以的话。好的。比尔，我知道，因为我在网上读到过，很多人在地下室里说你在往我们大脑里植入芯片，这太神奇了。
I love when people, when I hear that, my answer to that is always, to what end? Yeah, I know. Like, why do you? Why does he want to decide my head? Yeah, exactly. When I hear somebody say the government, I'm like, all right, we're done.
我喜欢听到人们这么说，我对此的回答总是：目的是什么？是啊，我知道。就像，你为什么要这么做？他为什么要控制我的大脑？是啊，没错。每当我听到有人说政府怎么怎么样，我就想，好吧，我们没话可说了。
But do you hear any of that? Does it make its way to you? Do you laugh about it sometimes? Does it alarm you when you hear these people saying, Bill Gates is trying to put a chip into everybody's brain? Yeah, well, I've had people come up to me on the street and yell at me that, you know, why am I tracking them? And I look at them like,
但你听到过这些吗？这些传言传到你耳朵里了吗？你有时会觉得好笑吗？当你听到这些人说比尔·盖茨试图在每个人的大脑里植入芯片时，你会感到惊慌吗？是啊，嗯，确实有人在街上走过来对我大喊大叫，问我为什么要追踪他们？我看着他们，心想，
But why are you? What am I gonna do with that information? Right. You know, so you do have to laugh about it, but it's also at the same time tragic that millions who would have been saved by the COVID vaccine stayed away from it because of all the online misinformation
但你为什么要这么做？我拿那些信息能做什么？对。你知道，所以你确实得对此一笑置之，但与此同时，这也是一场悲剧，因为数以百万计本可以被新冠疫苗拯救的人，却因为网上所有的错误信息而远离了疫苗。
that they were faced with. And whenever you get a pandemic saying, oh, there must be some evil genius behind this, that's not very adaptive. And we're not really ready for the next pandemic, which will come, hard to say when it's gonna come, but I thought that would make vaccines more popular. And so there's some work to be done here.
他们所面临的。每当你遇到一场大流行病，人们就说，哦，这背后一定有什么邪恶的天才，这种想法并不具备适应性。我们并没有真正为下一次大流行病做好准备，它终究会到来，很难说什么时候会来，但我原以为那会让疫苗更受欢迎。所以这里还有一些工作要做。
So Bill, with all the AI stuff that's being talked about, and I'm sure if you're like me, you'll kind of tune out a bit because there's so much of it. Well, I'm sure there's many parts. What's the most promising use of AI What's the most promising use of AI that you can see coming soon? I'm sure it's gonna fix a lot of things,
那么比尔，关于现在大家都在谈论的AI，我相信如果你像我一样，你可能会有点想屏蔽这些信息，因为内容实在太多了。嗯，我相信有很多方面。你认为近期能看到的AI最有前景的应用是什么？我相信它会解决很多问题，
but is there something that might be on the doorstep that you can talk about? Well, I'd say the most promising work is health and education. Even today, if you get like a set of blood tests back or an MRI test back, you know, if you get like a set of blood tests back or an MRI test back, you know, you get a confusing medical bill, you really should stick it in the AI
但有没有什么即将到来的东西是你愿意谈谈的？嗯，我会说最有前景的工作是在健康和教育领域。即使在今天，如果你拿到了一份血液检查报告或核磁共振检查报告，你知道，如果你拿到了一份血液检查报告或核磁共振检查报告，你知道，你收到了一份令人困惑的医疗账单，你真的应该把它交给AI，
and say, explain this to me like a sixth grader because it is so good at doing that. Okay. And so- God, I'd use it all the time. Helping people with medical things, and then in education, having a personal tutor that gets what you're confused about the level that you're at
然后说，像给六年级学生解释一样解释给我听，因为它在这方面非常擅长。好的。所以——天哪，我会一直用它。帮助人们处理医疗事务，然后在教育方面，拥有一个能理解你困惑之处、了解你所处水平的私人导师，
and knows how to encourage you, whether it's in math or writing papers. It's early days and it's being rolled out. And this will not only be profound for the United States, but in Africa, where we have fewer teachers and doctors than anywhere in the world. And so a chance for us to give them access to the kind of health that we take for granted,
并且知道如何鼓励你，无论是数学还是写论文。现在还处于早期阶段，正在推广中。这不仅对美国意义深远，在非洲也是如此，那里我们的教师和医生比世界上任何地方都少。所以这是一个机会，让我们能为他们提供我们认为理所当然的那种医疗服务，
AI in those two domains, we should push forward, get the accuracy up, and really surprise people by improving the health system a lot. And this question's coming from a person who has no idea how research and development happens in the medical science, but I think that you get an idea, then you gotta run it through a modeling thing, and you gotta test it all out.
AI在这两个领域，我们应该推动前进，提高准确性，并通过极大地改善医疗系统来真正让人们感到惊喜。这个问题来自一个完全不懂医学科学研发是如何进行的人，但我认为你有一个想法，然后你必须通过建模来运行它，你必须测试所有东西。
Am I right in assuming that AI can make this much, much faster such that we can track down maybe what the right equation is to fix cancer or any other of these incredibly damaging things, that maybe the process of elimination can happen much faster where we can reasonably expect to have some cures for some of these uncurable things perhaps in our lifetime?
我假设AI能让这个过程快得多，这样我们就能追踪到解决癌症或任何其他这些极其破坏性的疾病的正确方程式，也许排除法的过程可以快得多，我们可以合理地预期在我们的有生之年能治愈其中一些无法治愈的疾病，这种假设对吗？
Absolutely, and medicine has made a lot of progress. I mean, heart disease is way down. Cancer, we have a lot of things in the pipeline, but AI is going to accelerate all of that. Great, amazing. You know, I work in Alzheimer's and there's some great tools coming along because nobody should want to have that.
绝对正确，医学已经取得了很大进步。我的意思是，心脏病的发病率大幅下降。癌症方面，我们有很多正在研发的项目，但AI将加速所有这些进程。太棒了，太神奇了。你知道，我从事阿尔茨海默病的研究，有一些很棒的工具正在出现，因为没人想得那种病。
And even with HIV, this idea of the cure, the fact we can get it out maybe in four years instead of eight, we'll use AI to help accelerate that. That's amazing. Wow. We'll be right back. And back to the show. Your mom was really influential with you for sort of planting this early seed of philanthropy and giving back and using what you're given
即使是艾滋病，关于治愈的这个想法，我们可能在四年而不是八年内实现，我们将利用AI来帮助加速这一进程。这太神奇了。哇。我们马上回来。回到节目。你母亲对你影响很大，为你种下了慈善和回馈社会的早期种子，并以正确的方式使用你所拥有的东西，
in the right way, is that correct? of philanthropy and giving back and using what you're given in the right way, is that correct? Do you wanna speak about that at all? Yeah, absolutely. I mean, when you see your parents behave, that's more influential than what your parents say. And so they volunteered in the community, they gave what they could.
这是真的吗？慈善和回馈社会，并以正确的方式使用你所拥有的东西，这是真的吗？你想谈谈这个吗？是的，绝对。我的意思是，当你看到父母的行为时，那比父母说的话更有影响力。所以他们在社区里做志愿者，尽他们所能去给予。
And then as my mom saw- She was big in the community, they gave what they could, and then as my mom saw. She was big in the United Way, yes? Exactly, she put a lot of her time into that, both in our city, but also at the federal level. And so she was always telling me, okay, you've gotta run a United Way campaign and get back. Sadly, she died pretty young about 30 years ago. It was my dad who actually,
然后当我母亲看到——她在社区里很有影响力，他们尽其所能去给予，然后当我母亲看到。她在联合劝募协会（United Way）很有影响力，对吧？没错，她把很多时间都投入到了那项工作中，不仅在我们城市，而且在联邦层面。所以她总是告诉我，好吧，你必须开展一场联合劝募活动并回馈社会。遗憾的是，她在大约30年前很年轻时就去世了。其实是我父亲，
when I was still full-time at Microsoft, ran the foundation and got it going for the first 10 years, and set the culture in a very positive way. So he did get to see and participate in, you know, all those dictates that go back to my childhood. Are your kids being as observational as you were and benefiting from it like you did? Yeah, no, well, my kids, you know, are both lucky,
当我还全职在微软工作时，他经营着基金会，并让它在最初的10年里运转起来，以一种非常积极的方式确立了文化。所以他确实看到了并参与了，你知道，所有那些追溯到我童年的准则。你的孩子们像你一样善于观察并从中受益了吗？是啊，不，嗯，我的孩子们，你知道，都很幸运，
although being a child of somebody well known, I'm sure your kids experience some of it, it's got a lot of pluses, but some minuses as well. But are they following your great example, I guess is my question. Well, I'm giving them as a percentage of the wealth, a pretty small percentage. I mean, in absolute, it's a lot,
尽管作为名人的孩子，我相信你的孩子也经历过一些，这有很多好处，但也有一些坏处。但他们是在追随你的伟大榜样吗，我想这是我的问题。嗯，我给他们的财富比例，是一个相当小的比例。我的意思是，绝对值上，这很多，
and I do believe that they'll have their own careers and they'll be very generous with what they're doing, but I didn't decide that we would take that wealth and pass it down. 95% goes out through the foundation, and yet, I'm super happy with how hard they work and their values. My wife, Melinda, did a great job raising the kids
而且我确实相信他们会有自己的事业，并且在他们所做的事情上会非常慷慨，但我并没有决定我们要把那笔财富传下去。95%的钱通过基金会捐出去了，然而，我对他们工作有多努力以及他们的价值观感到非常高兴。我的妻子梅琳达在抚养孩子方面做得很好，
and it's worked out well. Yeah, amazing. What about, I want to know about that gut probe in a pill, like you just eat a pill. Describe that to me, because I just read headlines about it, I didn't really know anything about it. What is that technology and what is it used for? Probe eat a pill, like describe that to me, because I just read headlines about it, I didn't really know anything about it. What is that technology and what is it used for?
一切都很顺利。是的，太棒了。关于那个肠道探测药丸，就像你吃一颗药丸一样。给我描述一下，因为我只是读到了关于它的头条新闻，我真的不太了解。那是什么技术，它是用来做什么的？探测药丸，就像给我描述一下，因为我只是读到了关于它的头条新闻，我真的不太了解。那是什么技术，它是用来做什么的？
Probe and a pill. Yeah, like you eat a pill and it probes your gut. Oh boy. Yeah, so digestion is super complicated and that's why these nutritional fads come along and the New Yorker cartoon said, "'You better adopt this new nutritional fad quickly "'before they prove it doesn't work.'"
探测药丸。是的，就像你吃一颗药丸，它会探测你的肠道。天哪。是的，所以消化系统非常复杂，这就是为什么这些营养时尚会出现，而《纽约客》的漫画说：“你最好尽快采用这种新的营养时尚，在他们证明它无效之前。”
And what happens is that in your gut, there's a lot of bacteria they call the microbiome. And we're just now, as you swallow this capsule and it absorbs all of those bacteria, we see what's going on. We finally understand what's going on. And so our foundation works on malnutrition. These big pharmaceutical companies like Eli Lilly
发生的情况是，在你的肠道里，有很多被称为微生物群的细菌。我们现在才刚刚开始，当你吞下这个胶囊，它吸收了所有那些细菌，我们就能看到发生了什么。我们终于理解了正在发生的事情。所以我们的基金会致力于解决营养不良问题。这些像礼来公司这样的大型制药公司
work on overnutrition. And it turns out that we work together on the research because the same complex circuitry that allows poor kids to be malnourished. In the US, we have horrible levels of childhood obesity. And so as we're learning that, new drugs like these GLP-1 obesity drugs that as they get cheaper are gonna have a profound effect,
致力于解决营养过剩问题。事实证明，我们在研究上是合作的，因为导致贫困儿童营养不良的复杂回路是相同的。在美国，我们有可怕的儿童肥胖水平。所以当我们了解到这一点时，像这些GLP-1减肥药这样的新药，随着它们变得越来越便宜，将会产生深远的影响，
that's the type of innovation coming out. And yet, we didn't understand that until very recently. It's fascinating. And Sean's still mourning the new ban on red dye number three because it's such a staple in his diet as you can probably tell. That's my Swedish friend. He can't identify the cherry
这就是正在出现的创新类型。然而，直到最近我们才理解这一点。这太迷人了。肖恩还在为禁止红色3号染料而哀悼，因为正如你可能看出的那样，那是他饮食中的主食。那是我的瑞典朋友。他无法分辨樱桃味
and the strawberry flavored stuff. His brain is basically liquefied. But I will say, you talk about that, about obesity and childhood obesity, what is it? What is the difference in this country? Again, it sounds like I've been attacking this. I'm really not.
和草莓味的东西。他的大脑基本上已经液化了。但我会说，你谈到了那个，关于肥胖和儿童肥胖，那是什么？在这个国家有什么不同？再说一次，听起来我一直在攻击这一点。我真的没有。
I'm curious about things like, about childhood obesity compared to other countries and the nutrition and things that are allowed. Like, you've seen those things where they compare a product that is the same, but that's sold here and then sold in the UK and the list of ingredients is like double in this country with additives and preservatives, et cetera, et cetera.
我对诸如儿童肥胖与其它国家相比，以及营养和被允许使用的东西感到好奇。就像，你见过那些比较同一种产品，但在美国销售和在英国销售的情况，这个国家的配料表里添加剂和防腐剂等东西多了一倍，等等，等等。
I mean, is that a massive problem or no? Almost certainly not. Oh, really? Yeah, I mean mean our kids sit in front of the TV more than any other kids. So lack of activity alone explains most of this. Wow. And sadly when your parents are obese, the likelihood that you'll be obese
我的意思是，这是一个巨大的问题吗？几乎肯定不是。哦，真的吗？是的，我的意思是我们的孩子坐在电视机前的时间比任何其他国家的孩子都多。所以仅仅是缺乏活动就解释了大部分原因。哇。而且遗憾的是，当你的父母肥胖时，你肥胖的可能性
goes up pretty dramatically. And so the US in many respects, drug addiction, obesity, you could say as the world's richest country, all the problems of being rich are worse than the US than they are anywhere else. We're also the most innovative though. And that's why I'm not a pessimist at all. I do think.
会急剧上升。所以美国在许多方面，毒品成瘾、肥胖，你可以说作为世界上最富有的国家，所有富裕带来的问题在美国都比在其他任何地方更严重。不过我们也是最具创新力的。这就是为什么我一点也不悲观。我确实认为。
Wait, so it's just apathy? Is that what it is? No, your TV shows are too entertaining. Oh, okay. Exactly. It's all your fault. Not mine. Not mine.
等等，所以这只是冷漠？这就是原因吗？不，你们的电视节目太有趣了。哦，好吧。完全正确。这都是你的错。不是我的。不是我的。
What are you excited for the next five years? Sorry, Sean. No, that's okay. I just had one question about another issue, but yeah, sorry, well, right before that, but I do want to get to that. I'm really passionate about this because of the fires that just happened,
你对未来五年感到兴奋的是什么？抱歉，肖恩。不，没关系。我只是有一个关于另一个问题的问题，但是是的，抱歉，嗯，就在那之前，但我确实想谈谈那个。我对这个非常热衷，因为刚刚发生的火灾，
because of the constant droughts in California. And we talked to Kamala Harris about this like three, four years ago, when she was the Senator in California, is like most of the earth is water. And so when there's a shortage of water, I'm like, how can we not figure out how to desalinate water? And people say it's too expensive.
因为加州持续的干旱。我们三四年前和卡玛拉·哈里斯谈过这个，当时她是加州的参议员，就像地球上大部分是水。所以当水短缺时，我就想，我们怎么能不想出如何淡化海水的方法呢？人们说这太贵了。
Well, it's more expensive to not figure it out. And so what are your thoughts about that? And do you have any kind of desire to be in that world? Yeah, so I'm very involved in that because, we have to both do climate mitigation and climate adaptation and adaptation is a part of that's dealing with water shortages and more difficult weather. It takes a certain amount of energy to desalinate water.
嗯，不去想办法解决它更贵。所以你对此有什么看法？你是否有任何进入那个领域的愿望？是的，所以我非常参与其中，因为我们必须同时进行气候减缓和气候适应，而适应是应对水资源短缺和更恶劣天气的一部分。淡化海水需要一定的能量。
And so only by bringing the cost of energy down with things like solar or perhaps nuclear fission or fusion, then you get more water availability. 80% of water is used for agriculture. So you can afford to desalinate water for human consumption. You can't really afford to do it for agriculture, so you have to end up moving your farms to the places where there's enough water. You don't wanna pay to desalinate just to grow.
所以只有通过利用太阳能或核裂变或聚变等技术降低能源成本，你才能获得更多的水资源。80%的水用于农业。所以你可以负担得起淡化海水供人类消费。你真的负担不起将其用于农业，所以你最终必须把农场搬到有足够水的地方。你不想为了种植而支付淡化水的费用。
Unless you do, unless we figure out a way to do it. Unless you do, and people like, sadly, Jason Mayman, who obviously with his almond consumption has been destroying the planet, it's unbelievable the amount of water that goes to every one of your precious almonds that you just carelessly stuff in your mouth. But Bill, what is the, I was gonna ask you
除非你这样做，除非我们想出一种方法。除非你这样做，而且像杰森·梅曼这样的人，他显然因为食用杏仁一直在破坏地球，你随意塞进嘴里的每一颗珍贵的杏仁所消耗的水量简直令人难以置信。但比尔，什么是，我本来要问你
about what you're excited about the next five years. What are we gonna do about energy sources going forward? What can we do? Is there, have we reached peak oil? What are we gonna do with fossil fuels? Is there, have we reached peak oil? What are we going to do with fossil fuels? Can we keep it going in this direction? What do you think about that? Well, I'm very hopeful that between expanding wind and solar and getting both types of nuclear, nuclear fission and fusion, to get safer and cheaper, that even with all this demand for energy,
关于你对未来五年感到兴奋的事情。我们未来将如何处理能源来源？我们能做什么？我们是否已经达到了石油峰值？我们将如何处理化石燃料？我们是否已经达到了石油峰值？我们将如何处理化石燃料？我们能继续朝着这个方向发展吗？你对此怎么看？嗯，我非常有希望，在扩大风能和太阳能以及获得两种核能——核裂变和聚变，使其更安全、更便宜之间，即使有所有这些能源需求，
like electric cars or electric heat pumps, AI data centers, that we'll be able to get ahead of that and still have cheap electricity, even though we'll get rid of all of the terrible CO2 emissions. So we are gonna have to transition away from coal and natural gas in the decades ahead.
比如电动汽车或电动热泵、AI数据中心，我们也将能够领先于此，并仍然拥有廉价的电力，即使我们将摆脱所有可怕的二氧化碳排放。所以我们必须在未来的几十年里从煤炭和天然气转型。
I mean, and that's gonna be a painful transition, I imagine. Not if we innovate the cost of these other things down. Electric cars are getting cheaper. Eventually you do get to the point where the substitute is as cheap as the dirty thing was. And in the long run, that's what we need to do so that we get global adoption of green approaches.
我的意思是，那将是一个痛苦的转型，我想。如果我们能通过创新降低这些其它东西的成本，就不会。电动汽车正变得越来越便宜。最终你会达到这样一个点，即替代品和肮脏的东西一样便宜。从长远来看，这就是我们需要做的，以便我们实现绿色方法的全球采用。
Well, but educate me if you would, to the extent that you know, if you get an electric car and you get all these people who get them and they're great, and then some people like to virtue signal with them and shame other people. But the components, there's so many of the components that go into the car are petroleum based,
嗯，但如果你愿意的话，请教教我，据你所知，如果你买了一辆电动汽车，你得到了所有这些买车的人，他们很棒，然后有些人喜欢用它们来展示美德并羞辱其他人。但是组件，进入汽车的组件中有这么多是石油基的，
whether it's the actual components themselves or traveling those cars to their destinations or across oceans and stuff, right? You know about all this. Is there any way that we can mitigate all of those other things as well so that we're not relying on petroleum for everything? You know, absolutely, and we measure that.
无论是组件本身，还是将这些汽车运送到目的地或跨越海洋等等，对吧？你知道所有这些。有没有什么方法可以减轻所有这些其它东西，这样我们就不会在所有事情上都依赖石油了？你知道，绝对，我们测量过。
Anybody who buys an electric car, as you say, it's not zero emissions, but it is dramatically less than a gasoline car. Right. And we're learning to make the batteries using less energy and less environmental things, like new ways of finding lithium. So the accounting on, okay,
任何购买电动汽车的人，正如你所说，它不是零排放，但它比汽油车少得多。对。我们正在学习使用更少的能源和更少的环境影响来制造电池，比如寻找锂的新方法。所以关于，好的，
how do we have the most environmentally clean car? We're doing a very good job tracking that. And consumers who help create demand for electric vehicles, they deserve a little bit a sense of virtue because the more we buy, the more the price goes down and the more we. I agree, I was playing obviously, but I do agree. I do agree.
我们如何拥有最环保的汽车？我们在追踪这方面做得非常好。而那些帮助创造电动汽车需求的消费者，他们值得拥有一点点美德感，因为我们买得越多，价格就越低，我们就越。我同意，我显然是在开玩笑，但我确实同意。我确实同意。
Bill, what's the rest of your day look like? What are your, is your average day. Inspiring the person who told him to do this. Is your average day split 50-50 between sort of personal pleasure, silly stuff, and also saving the world at the other half? Or I'll bet the ratio's not 50-50. But do you get a little time to be stupid doing something?
比尔，你的一天剩下的时间是怎么安排的？你的平均一天是怎样的？激励那个告诉他做这件事的人。你的一天是50-50地分配在个人乐趣、愚蠢的事情和拯救世界之间吗？或者我敢打赌比例不是50-50。但你有一点时间做点愚蠢的事情吗？
If so, what is it? I do. In my 20s, I was monomaniacal in my work. But now, although I work 50 hours a week and travel a lot, I play a fair bit of tennis, I play a lot of pickleball. I love reading, I love, you know, TV shows that you guys have made, that's super fun. Little bit of golf?
如果有，那是什么？我有。在我20多岁的时候，我在工作中是偏执狂。但现在，虽然我每周工作50个小时，经常出差，但我打不少网球，我打很多匹克球。我喜欢阅读，我喜欢，你知道，你们制作的电视节目，那超级有趣。打一点高尔夫球？
No, I'm not doing much golf. I like tennis and pickleball, because slightly better exercise. Sure, sure, gotcha. What is the one thing that you know how to do that everyone would be kind of surprised about? Do you have like a little hobby, like are you a great like drawer?
不，我不怎么打高尔夫。我喜欢网球和匹克球，因为锻炼效果稍微好一点。当然，当然，明白了。你有什么大家都觉得会很惊讶的技能吗？你有什么小爱好吗，比如你是一个伟大的画家？
Do you cook? Yeah, like are you a knitter? Is there anything that's sort of a sneaky little talent that people might be surprised about? Like are you a great whistler, you know? That's pretty good. That qualifies. On cue, not bad.
你会做饭吗？是的，比如你是一个编织者吗？有什么小才艺是人们可能会感到惊讶的吗？比如你是一个伟大的口哨手，你知道吗？那相当不错。这算数。随叫随到，还不错。
I'm good at sleeping on planes. Oh, that's a great talent. That is a great talent. Now, are you a savory or sweet person? Do you have a sweet tooth? Yeah, no, I try and not have too much peanut brittle around because I would eat anything that's around. Wow.
我擅长在飞机上睡觉。哦，那是一个伟大的天赋。那确实是一个伟大的天赋。那么，你是喜欢咸味还是甜味的人？你有吃甜食的习惯吗？是的，不，我尽量不放太多的花生糖，因为我会吃掉周围的任何东西。哇。
Sugar's a bad deal for me. Very dangerous. Well, it's good that you're not too distracted with silly things because we need you there on the stick doing whatever you are doing and what you will continue to do, we hope. So thank you so much for what you've done, what you're gonna do,
糖对我来说是个坏东西。非常危险。嗯，很高兴你没有被愚蠢的事情分心，因为我们需要你在那里坚持做你正在做的事情，以及我们希望你继续做的事情。所以非常感谢你所做的一切，你将要做的一切，
and thank you for spending an hour with us, truly. Yeah, that was fun, thank you guys. Honor to meet you. What an absolute thrill. Thank you so much for your time. So cool, thanks Bill. Thank you Bill. All right.
也感谢你花了一个小时和我们在一起，真的。是的，那很有趣，谢谢你们。很荣幸见到你。真是太激动了。非常感谢你的时间。太酷了，谢谢比尔。谢谢比尔。好的。
Thank you, enjoy the rest of your day. All right. Thank you, sir. See you buddy. All right. You enjoy the rest of your day. All right, sir. Yeah, buddy Bye bye pal I Felt like I was a real blowhard today. I'm sorry. I don't have a lot of opinions and they're good opinions No, I felt very I felt very blowhardy. I'm so sorry I know well
谢谢，享受你剩下的一天。好的。谢谢你，先生。再见，伙计。好的。你享受你剩下的一天。好的，先生。是的，伙计，再见，朋友。我今天感觉自己像个吹牛大王。我很抱歉。我没有很多意见，而且它们是好的意见。不，我感觉非常，我感觉非常吹牛。我很抱歉，我知道，嗯。
You know what you get somebody like that on the show and you you you want to like you want to talk about all the stuff That is complicated and big stuff, I want him to answer big questions. I know, I get that. Like big macro questions. I get that. How can we save it? Is there any way that we can change opinion in the world? Yeah, yeah, right, right, right.
你知道，你在节目中请到这样的人，你想要，你想要谈论所有复杂和重大的事情，我希望他回答重大问题。我知道，我明白。比如宏观的大问题。我明白。我们怎么能拯救它？有没有什么方法可以改变世界上的观点？是的，是的，对，对，对。
It's almost like everybody's looking, to your point Will, it's like everybody's looking for that guy who has all the answers. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But I mean, I wanted to ask him, people like that, do you have perspective about being one of the people that changed the fucking world? No, I wanted to ask him, people like that, do you have perspective about being one of the people that changed the fucking world?
这几乎就像每个人都在寻找，正如你所说的威尔，就像每个人都在寻找那个拥有所有答案的人。是的，是的，是的。但我的意思是，我想问他，像那样的人，你对成为改变他妈的世界的人之一有什么看法吗？不，我想问他，像那样的人，你对成为改变他妈的世界的人之一有什么看法吗？
No, I know. There's like 10 or 20 people like Einstein and him and like Steve Jobs and- He and I are on a short list of people who- Wait, wait, wait, wait, back up, back up, back up. I agree. I know, I'm saying what you're saying, dude. I'm agreeing with you.
不，我知道。有10到20个人像爱因斯坦和他，还有像史蒂夫·乔布斯和——他和我在一个短名单上，那些人——等等，等等，等等，退后，退后，退后。我同意。我知道，我在说你所说的，伙计。我同意你的观点。
The number of smiles that Will has created as opposed to computers. No, what I'm saying is he and I, yeah, dude, I'm making your point for you. That's when I have changed. He's got to like, talk about like, you know, when you get to the end of your life, and like we've talked about it before, you know,
威尔创造的笑容数量与计算机相比。不，我所说的是他和我在，是的，伙计，我正在为你表达你的观点。这就是我改变的时候。他必须，谈论，你知道，当你走到生命尽头时，就像我们之前谈过的那样，你知道，
did I use my years right? Like this guy, I mean, I'm sure some people have issues with him, like with everybody, but my goodness, the amount of effect he has set over this world. And he's still doing it. I know, I know he. The other thing that I'm excited about,
我是否正确地利用了我的岁月？像这家伙，我的意思是，我相信有些人对他有意见，就像对每个人一样，但天哪，他对这个世界产生的影响力。而且他还在继续这样做。我知道，我知道他。我感到兴奋的另一件事是，
you know, is his book. He's got this new book coming out that's, you know, about like how this all started for him, how his brain started going and how he got excited. Was it the biography? Yeah, yes, I believe so. Yeah, it's called Source Code. It comes out February, but yeah, hopefully there's
你知道，是他的书。他有一本新书要出版，是关于这一切是如何为他开始的，他的大脑是如何开始运转的，以及他是如何感到兴奋的。是传记吗？是的，我相信是这样。是的，它叫《源代码》（Source Code）。它二月出版，但是的，希望有
an audio portion of it that I can listen to. Oh no, Jamie, no. Yeah, I still don't get it. It's left to right, top to bottom, right? You don't know what you're missing. I just had such a good read. Oh God, you don't know what you guys, it would give you so many more references.
我可以听的音频部分。哦不，杰米，不。是的，我还是不明白。是从左到右，从上到下，对吧？你不知道你错过了什么。我刚刚读得很好。哦天哪，你不知道你们，它会给你更多的参考资料。
You'd be so much more interesting. No wonder you're so bland. You have nothing in there. There's a reference. Did we stop recording or are we still rolling? No, we're still going. Source code. Source code is the book.
你会变得更有趣。难怪你这么平淡。你里面什么都没有。有一个参考。我们停止录音了吗，还是我们还在录？不，我们还在继续。源代码。源代码是那本书。
Go out and read it. Because all the prophets are going to go to, me? Not his pocket, something really good. I should know this, but it's all for charity. So. That's great, as most everything he does. Exactly. That's so cool.
去读它吧。因为所有的利润都要去，我？不是他的口袋，是非常好的东西。我应该知道这一点，但这一切都是为了慈善。所以。那太棒了，就像他做的大多数事情一样。没错。太酷了。
Source code. I also love the work that I wanted to get more into the... Oh, here we go, Jesus Christ. You couldn't even fucking get... I wanted to get into the biotechnology. The biotechnology. Why, why, Sean? Into the biotechnology.
源代码。我也喜欢我想更多地了解的那个工作……哦，开始了，耶稣基督。你甚至不能他妈的得到……我想进入生物技术。生物技术。为什么，为什么，肖恩？进入生物技术。
Biotechnology. Is exciting. technology into the biotech-nology! Bio! Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
生物技术。是令人兴奋的。技术进入生物技术！生物！聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。
Smart. Less is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armgerf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLess是100%有机的，由贝内特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗伯·阿姆格夫手工制作。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。